nicolas vidal bonjour bonjour olivier
bonjour heureux de vous retrouver ce
matin alors c'est la rentrée scolaire
placée sous haute surveillance sanitaire
à quoi faut-il s'attendre pour vous
allécher olivier sous leur ai dit c'est
le grand jour de la rentrée c'est la
rentrée scolaire ce matin pour des
millions d'élèves et pour huit cent
mille enseignants qui ont la boule au
ventre les mêmes boîtes et pour certains
la goutte au nez et un test pcr dans la
poche de derrière ailleurs hier soir
olivier j'ai préparé méticuleusement mon
kart avanies mettant mon passé dit et
renault - s'cusez moi mon carnet
scolaire mon combat est ma règle pour
bien respecter les gestes de
distanciation sociale j'ai aussi préparé
mon bidon deux gels hydroalcooliques mon
stock de masques et mais moufles pour ne
pas s'enrhumer pourquoi car ce matin ce
matin ces journées fenêtre ouverts dans
les écoles françaises et c'est le
professeur blanc caire avec son nouveau
look qui l'a dit répété à cette rentrée
va être pétillante à défaut d'être
postillonnant tu oui car pour cette
rentrée les règles sanitaires sont
montés au niveau 2 couleur jaune 2 comme
les deux mains de distanciation sociale
imposée lorsque nous chers élèves feront
du sport alors pour la course à pied un
ses joueurs bien sûr mais lorsqu'il est
question de handball de basket ou de
hockey sur goudron ça va être un
tantinet plus compliqué en réalité c'est
toute l'histoire du sport collectif qui
va être chamboulée quel progressiste ce
jean michel2 plus c'est le retour aux
présidentielles dès ce matin vous savez
c'est ce mot horrible devenu très à la
mode qui vont bien celui du référent
bondissant pour parler d'un ballon on
apprend aussi que dans ce protocole il
est prévu des désinfections très
fréquent des surfaces les plus
fréquemment touchés alors cela nous
promet des sessions de pulvérisation dès
ce matin à coude hectolitres de gel
hydroalcoolique sur le cher tableau vert
ou surface weleda c'est l'avènement du
cours à moitié effacée mais totalement
désinfecter et ça c'est le plus
important dans le monde merveilleux de
l'éducation nationale du gestes
barrières olivier alors franchement tout
de même nicolas le ministre de la santé
s qui n'a pas raison prendre ses
précautions pour assurer la sécurité des
élèves et du corps enseignant
mais bien sûr vous avez raison bien sûr
car ce que vous ne savez pas c'est que
jaume ciel bancaire il a changé le
boulot cet été pour devenir un véritable
directeur des achats industriels je
m'explique imaginez le nombre de
catalogues qui a dû consulter pour
choisir est conseillé aux collectivités
territoriales concernées des dizaines de
milliers de détecteurs de co2 ou de
purificateurs d'air alors qu'il continue
de préconiser coûte que coûte d'ouvrir
les fenêtres c'est ça le prime active et
éducatif et lorsque l'on sait que l'été
est propice aux soldes ça n'a pas dû
être triste au ministère et il faut
parler aussi de cette idée géniale du
contact racing apparemment assez mieux
de l'écrire de le dire en anglais allez
comprendre à être encore une histoire de
starter edition alors ce contact racing
c'est de ce traçage pourparlers france
est il un poste quoi et bien la
fermeture de la classe dès le premier
cas de contamination relevés le retour
du 10 en ciel dans les écoles alors je
me permets ce petit modestes conseils
jean-michel bancaire ne fermez pas trop
vite les centres aérés car il risque d'y
avoir du monde d'ici la fin du mois en
ce qui concerne les collèges et les
lycées les élèves qu'à contacter non
vaccinés ou pas complètement vaccinés
est bien pour eux c'est retour d'un
canapé du salon devant de grands et
plantes écran plat cher à qui héberge
and senior banker tardy c'est une sorte
de quarantaine éducative version
nouvelle vague un brin punitive et enfin
il y à cette directive toujours inscrite
noir sur blanc caire dans le protocole
que je vous lis limitation du brassage
par nîmes obligatoire alors à première
vue on ne sait pas trop si c'est la
limitation ou le niveau qui est
obligatoire alors comment ça va se
passer eh bien on ne peut supputer sa
soeur à cette heure je me hasarde ce
matin a évoqué des pistes avec vous
olivier pour cela je me suis mis un très
court instant dans la tête de jean
michel blanquer alors j'ai pensé des
sens uniques dans les couloirs des
rocades d'accès aux escaliers des
barrières pour aller aux toilettes
toujours à sens unique des voies
d'insertion pour les élèves vaccinés ou
des feux tricolores qui autorise la
marche en crabe et toujours avec le
masque et là je pense que pour donner
une idée assez précise de ce protocole
il faut écouter ou réécouter le sketch
de raymond de bosses sur le sens
interdit essayez ça va devenir plus qu'à
relier alors pourtant jean michel
blanquer rassure que cette nouvelle
rentrée sera la plus normale possible
on attendait pas moins du professeur
blanc caire qui nous répètent à longueur
de médias depuis une semaine d'ailleurs
à force on ne sait plus si c'est
jean-michel bancaire qui passe à la télé
ou s'ils lui même la télévision temps on
le voit nous assurer tous les jours que
tout va bien madame la marquise enrhumé
alors si on résume la journée à venir
dans nos écoles lavage de mains très
intensive d infection massive des
espaces utilisés masse que pour tout le
monde sens de circulation chaotique pour
éviter les brassages ouverture des
fenêtres a bien entendu et les courants
d'air et plus dans la classe activités
en présentiel mais toujours à distance
je voulais 10 et moment du repas à la
cantine la version de tetris ou rubicube
en dernier recours fermetures de classes
pour les écoles et évictions des élèves
pas vacciner ou pas c'est vacciner dans
les lycées et les collèges quand on vous
dit que cette nouvelle rentrée presque
normal le nier relève de la mauvaise foi
et comme l'écrivait george orwell
revenus très à la mode en cette période
de recul inquiétant de liberté je cite
ce qui constitue l'essence de l'être
humain c'est de ne pas rechercher la
perfection et bien au moins avec jean
michel blanquer on n'est jamais déçu
merci beaucoup nicolas pour votre édito
ce matin un édito nicolas vidal a
retrouvé bien évidemment sur les réseaux
sociaux